Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with I want to make sure
that my microphone is on. I thought All
right, good to go.
>> We got a very special guest tonight, a
pastor friend of mine all the way from
Canada and he runs a ministry called
Button to Christ. I'm going to invite
him in right now. What is up, Pastor
Patrick?
>> Praise God.
>> How you doing tonight, brother?
Very good. Hallelujah. In Jesus name.
Everything is good.
>> I want to pull up your um this is your
YouTube channel. I want to pull up your
website here. It's called Button to
Christ. Tell us a little bit about your
ministry, how you got the name, what you
guys do, how all this started, what what
even got you into ministry.
>> Okay. You know what? The way the Lord
started this ministry is just amazing
because we were a church and looking for
things to do. And we had the question uh
if you need somebody to do a
deliverance, see the power of prayer,
what do you do? Who can we find in the
church? And we start to scan the church
around and can't find pinpoint
unanimously who we could go to. And then
we said to ourselves, why don't we be
that people and start to pray and see
the power of God. So we just started to
pray and we started to see mountains
move. We started with like five young
men or three young men coming to the
altar. There's a power when you go to
the altar and we started to pray at the
altar and we're talking one hour, two
hours, three hours, four hours while
other guys play games and dominoes.
We've been praying and we started to
experience powerful things in for
example there's one night where they're
praying and the altar start to
physically shake and
one more young man joined until we are
like 18 young men at the altar and then
the women saw and said how can we be
part of it so they started to meet in a
room next door until we merged the team
together and my brother we seen some
powerful things. So, we didn't really
have the name Button to Christ yet. As
the ministry evolved and grew, we
decided and we asked the Lord to give us
a name. And we went through several
names until a young lady came up with
button to Christ. And from the moment I
saw it, the Lord says that relationship,
that's button, button that button up
your shirt, close relationship. But I
want to highlight something that's so
powerful. During the time of the
ministry, how we knew that God was
calling us to do deliverance was there
was a a a case in Toronto where this
young lady was possessed. And the
brother called me and I'm asking him,
"How do you know she's possessed?" And
he said, "She was ripping up the Bible."
So they came to the meeting, the prayer
meeting. And during the prayer meeting,
she just start to act strange and we
felt power coming down. And we went out,
me and my prayer partner, to pray and
say, "Lord, what is this?" And we felt a
power like it want to squash us. And
that start to open up our eyes. We see
people run out of the church,
>> you know, just the atmosphere changing.
We see the the pianist run to the piano
and start to play. Total confusion. And
then the next, the Lord gave me a vision
that I were at a park close by. a park
with a a river, a bridge. So when I got
to church, I said to my prayer partner
and she said, "I had the same dream that
we were at the park." We said, "Let's go
there." So we went to the park for
lunch. And when we went to the park for
lunch, there was about eight or nine of
us, including some children. When we
were going to pray, now it's a public
park. We held hands together and one of
the lady squeezing my hand like, "Open
your eyes." When I look, there's a bird,
a bigsized bird in the center making
circles and looking up on us. And I'm
like, God, how can this be? There's no
way a bird going to get there. This is
impossible.
>> So I said, God, if this is the
situation, allow the bird to come and
perch upon me. Lo and behold, the bird
came and perch right here. And all the
children running like everybody's
running from me. And when the bird
perched there, he turned its beak to me
like it's going to poke me. And and
somebody's saying something is wrong
with the bird. And I start to talk and
explain to everybody and the bird not
moving until finally the bird flew down
on the table and then surge up into the
hill.
>> Wow.
>> Those are the miracles. God was showing
us that I'm with you and this ministry
is going to do powerful work. I had no
idea that these things were coming. Lord
have mercy. That's just a little intro
about the ministry.
>> So your background, I mean, were you
raised Christian? Was there Did you ever
have any experiences with this? You
never saw yourself getting involved in
deliverance ministry, but you started to
be in environments where people were
starting to manifest and things like
that.
>> Okay. So, you know, a lot of people
asked me, they said, "Were you
demonpossessed before?" And I'm like,
"Me? I have no idea about [laughter]
demon possession." So I grew up in the
church and as many young people, you go
to the city, go to school and you kind
of just leave the church and then when
the Lord pressed you and pressed you and
you got back in, you're not really
serious. There's a lot of Adventists
that is not serious
>> and they don't believe in spiritual
warfare. So when I got back in and even
when the ministry started, I didn't know
that it was going to be a deliverance
ministry that prays for people to be
delivered.
But people, there's such a hunger for
the word of God and for genuine people
that prays and see things happen. So all
of a sudden people want prayers and they
are coming and demonpossessed people are
coming and we're asking the Lord what do
I do now and we are learning on the job.
So a lot of the deliverance we learn on
the job like when we are praying and the
demon won't go we are like God show us
which scripture do we use now what do we
do God
>> and the Lord start to teach us and say
okay use Matthew 27 re use Revelation 12
use Psalms 3 we notice that they're
afraid of Psalms 3 I'm like yes Lord
they are such afraid of Psalms 3 I don't
know where the power come from in the
word like Psalms 3 But when we read
Psalms 3, we have hundreds of
testimonies using Psalms 3 that the
demon will just muzzle and the person
cannot speak again. So you better fasten
your seat belt because I have some
testimonies that makes me
>> I know you do, man. I've heard some
crazy stuff. You know, when when I first
met you, you were talk you're telling me
how many people were on your team and
you're saying now we got a pretty big
team, but most of them aren't like boots
on the ground. you know, they're they're
doing the phone stuff or something like
that. And you said because not everybody
can handle going in a room and seeing
somebody levitate. I'm like, what? Like,
you've seen some pretty crazy stuff. I
want to ask some questions because
there's there's kind of this taboo thing
about deliverance. You know, I I know
that Jesus said in the, you know, the
great commission that you will go out
into all the world and heal the sick,
raise the dead, and cast out devils. But
it seems like now in today's society, in
the Christian world, we look at this
like it's some taboo controversial thing
that we're not supposed to cast out
devils. I don't understand why that is.
And I don't know if it's because there's
been so many fake things, you know,
other ministries out there where they
see um what do you call it? Like a lot
of this just sensationalized things or I
don't know really what it is. But I
guess my question is, how do you know
the difference in somebody that's
like really casting out demons? Is there
a such thing as a fake exorcism or a
fake deliverance? What What do you think
about that? Do you Do you think all
ministries are good that are casting out
devils?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> There's a lot of fake ministries. As a
matter of fact, we just did a case last
night and it's next level. And the thing
is this individual went to a prophet. so
to speak, prophet. And that prophet
actually astrop project because we're
going to talk some deep things that a
witch can astrop project come into your
body. That witch, there were several
witches that spoke to us and tell us
things that happened 27 years ago
between that young woman and her friend
in school. Unbelievable things that
happened. So what I'm saying now is that
there's fake people who pretend to cast
out demon when they actually bring more
demon into your body.
>> Yeah. So we find that um being a
deliverance ministry we find that
seventh day Adventists don't really
believe like majority
>> don't really believe and when we are
going to pray for people and we get to
like a church invite us if it's 600
people will line up for 15 for 20 hours
>> wow
>> for prayers we will pray from 7 in the
evening until the next morning and
people line up still and they will
witness especially if it's a open
situation where we'll bring them to the
altar. People will see people come and
we start to pray and the demon will
manifest and speak and they will start
to form at the mouth like the Bible said
everything and people are saying we
never see this happen before but so many
people are being delivered that it's
it's beyond explaining. So in other
words then deliverance is real. If I
were there was one case I was doing
where somebody called me from a
different country. We did a we do a lot
of a deliverance through Zoom. Somebody
called me and told me that a little boy
8 years old went to school and somebody
gave him something to drink and from the
moment he drank it he become demonp
possessed. They have him in the
hospital. They don't know what to do. So
there was an Adventist the mom who
called me and the aunt goes to Sunday
church and when they got to the hospital
and they put this on speaker because if
you give an Adventist to pray for
somebody who demonp possessed they're
going to be praying like this Lord
please help this person Lord and may you
bless them and help them to get well.
>> Yeah
>> you give me to pray.
>> Yeah I'm like Lord you have given us
power and authority. Matthew 10 verse1
we have the authority therefore I
command you now I know you are inside
there and you have to leave now then the
demon is like he knows I'm here but if
you go and pray some weak prayer the
demon is like where they get you from
you know what I mean so this now
>> I'm praying for them in the hospital and
the demon start to manifest and the
nurse and everybody said take him out of
here t so they took him out
>> into the car and we have the Adventist
and the Sunday keeper. The Adventist who
is like 41 years old, she's just crying,
"Lord, I've never seen anything like
this in my life. Lord, help me."
>> Wow.
>> While the other Sunday keeper is like,
"Tell me what to do. I have the
anointing oil. I know how to fight."
>> The Adventist was so weak, my brother,
>> that by the time we're done, we have to
be praying for her. She's broken. I've
never seen this in my life. What is
happening?
Yeah,
>> that's how we operate. We don't know how
to fight and that's why we are not
seeing deliverance and power and that's
why we are not claiming the word and
coming with the power because we don't
believe. So there have to a great
awakening within the advent movement
because we have the word, we have the
truth, but we are afraid of demons.
>> Yeah. Oh, I I I believe it man because I
I didn't grow up Adventist. I grew up
non-denominational charismatic churches.
So, I seen a lot of the healing stuff
and probably a lot of fake stuff. Um,
but when I got convicted about or when I
just it didn't take any kind of
convincing for me. I was on a search for
truth. And when I saw the fourth
commandment and what it what the Sabbath
was, like I was all in. I was like, "The
Bible says it, I'm doing it." And so, I
started going to Adventist churches
because they were the ones that were
keeping the Sabbath and they also
understand what happens when you die and
the truth about hell and all that. But,
I did notice that. I started realizing
that it seemed like the power of prayer,
not even just with demonic possession,
but even with believing in healing and
things like that, it seemed like there
was a lack of belief. You know, it's
kind of like, uh, well, Lord, if it's
your will, we we just pray that this
person will get better. Um, but it
wasn't like, "Lord, you promised, you
know, we we have promises that if we
claim them, we can put our name in that
promise." And it's it's like a legal
document. It's like when you go to court
and the lawyer says, you know, uh, act
so and so, so and so, you're quoting the
law and that judge says, "You're right."
You know, ain't that how it is? Like a
legal court.
>> Amen. Because you know what? A lot of
times I never pray and say if it is your
will Lord I ask Lord I'm coming in your
will
>> direct me I'm coming promises when you
come with the promises you don't come
with doubt when you pray and you end the
prayer and say Lord if it is your will
even though it's the ultimate if it is
God's will but we use that as a back
door when I claim the promise listen we
have some wrestling with the demon
there's a demon that manifest last night
And he said, "I'm not telling you who I
am.
>> I'm inside of her and I'm you can't get
me out and I'm not telling you." I said,
"Listen, when you hear the name of Jesus
Christ, you have to tell me. It's not a
if." I said, "Look around. See the
powerful angels around. You see the
angel, listen." And then I said, "In the
name of Jesus Christ, now I need to know
who you are." And he said, "Okay, I'm
like I'm mind control. I'm in her mind.
I caused the headache. Lady have
headaches for two years now.
>> MRI, all the the the the the tablet, the
medication and nothing stopped.
>> Now she tell me, I caused the headache.
I said, listen now. I'm going to ask you
a question. What is your legal rights in
Jesus name?
>> And then he start to tell me, oh, she
opened a door when she was her mother,
her ancestors, they used to worship. And
he start to tell me. So now I calm down
and I said okay uh such and such you're
going to confess that and she came back
to herself she confessed it and I said I
have the rights now you will have to
leave this headache is going to leave
now because according to the the court
of law according to the word of God
listen you see when I start to do that
brethren the headache was gone we going
to bring her on the all night program
December 31st we're going to bring her
on to testify no more headache
God want us to use us, use the
scripture, use the logics when the devil
pretend and said, "I'm not leaving."
>> You can command him and he can tell you
how to get out.
>> Listen, I got to tell you this one. Let
me
>> before the next question, I have to tell
you this because it came to my thought.
There was one time we were praying and
it was the Sabbath was finishing and
we're closing down the program and a
young lady walk in and said, "I'm from
such and such. I'm Adventist, but I am
going through battles. I need help now."
And she just sit in the deliverance seat
right at the altar. And by the time I
start to come to pray, the demon says,
"We're not leaving. We have her. We stop
her from getting jobs. We have her not
able to marry again. We just allow her
to study but she won't get any job. And
they're naming
>> and I said in the name of Jesus Christ
like who give you authority to speak and
tell me we are subjected to you so we
have to speak. So I said okay then in
the name of Jesus Christ what is your
legal rights? He said her ancestors used
to worship moolak. Oh,
>> and because they worship Moolak, I have
the rights to her and to her children
and her children.
I said, "Okay, then we got to break
this.
>> Tell me now in Jesus Christ's name, what
is the stronghold and what we need to do
for you to lose her?" And he said,
"Listen, you got to pray and get her to
confess on behalf." And he said,
"Listen, you guys are not fasting now,
so you can't get us out. We only come
out through prayer and fasting. We are
torment. We are sent to her and she
prays too much and we are in torment.
Please go and fast and pray and get us
out. We want relief. I've never heard
that in ministry.
>> Wow.
>> The devil is telling us what to do. And
we as Adventists don't even know what to
do.
>> We see the scripture. We heard about
demon and people running through the
door. We're not ready for the last
movement yet. We're not ready for the
battle. We don't ready for the the the
great controversy yet. We're we
>> Yeah. You're making me think right now.
You know, occultists, spiritual
spiritualists, newagers,
Satanist, these people have more faith
in what they believe and more
discipline. the you know new age people
will meditate for hours and they'll come
out of their body and meet meet ascended
masters and all this stuff for hours
they're in prayer uh how many how long
do we pray usually you know if I
remember you know I pray in the morning
or something like that um when it comes
to like quoting scripture and stuff a
witch they'll be right they'll be making
spells casting spells and binding and
and mixing all these potions and they're
really wanting to see results and yet we
won't even quote scripture or memorize
script scripture or find exactly what we
need to. So, I did have a question about
what you're saying because I've heard
people say when it comes to deliverance
ministry, you should never talk to the
demon. You're not supposed to talk to
the demon. But what I'm hearing from you
is that you have to command that this
demon tell you how they have right in
there and how to get them out and they
have to tell you. And so, it makes me
think of I don't know where people got
this idea. You're not supposed to talk
to the demon because Jesus went up and
and said, "Who are you?" And he said,
"My name is Legion. We are many."
>> Jesus talked to that demon and got rid
of the thing.
>> So,
>> okay.
>> What what are some examples of things
that can invite people in and and how
what what kind of steps are we supposed
to do? Like, give us kind of like a a
rundown on things that invite the enemy
in and how you're supposed to handle it.
Do you talk to him? Do you get them?
>> Yeah. Tell us who don't command the
demon to speak is most time when they're
afraid.
>> So they look for a back door to say you
don't have to speak. I want to tell you
a lot of deliverance we have done.
>> The demon actually told us how to get
them out.
>> Wow.
>> Because we command authority over them.
We have power over them through the word
of Jesus Christ. Matthew 10:1 the Lord
give us authority but we are not using
the authority. So what happened if you
start to ask the day the devil favors
and the congregate and the there's time
when the Lord tell me tell him not to
speak bind them so they don't speak
again
>> I have a case where
I went to a church to do a seminar and
when I went to the church to do a
seminar as soon as I walk in a young
lady got up and run out and it was so
dramatic that they run after her
>> and They brought her back in and when
I'm up there presenting the pastor is
going to me like you have to stop. She
she can't speak. So I I stopped and said
bring her and this is in front of the
congregation. They brought her up and I
speaking to her and her mouth is musl
>> and we prayed and rebuke and she can't
speak. So I said okay keep on with the
service. Let's take her to the prayer
room. When we got in the prayer room,
the prayer team run and said they're
going to pray for her. I gave them the
opportunity. They prayed like for a half
an hour and she can't speak still. So
when I got in there with the two
pastors, I said, "Okay,
I want you to write where's the demon is
holding you." The demon just her hand
just locked up. Wow.
>> So I pushed the pen in like this and she
wrote my tongue. She wrote first of all,
what is happening to me? M
>> a good Adventist would say we don't know
we are trying to help.
>> I'm like Satan lock your mouth and he's
going to lose you.
>> We hit the nail on the head. And now she
wrote my tongue is sealed to my mouth.
Now we know now. So I said under the
authority of Jesus Christ I command you
now loose her mouth. And she just start
to speak instant.
>> Wow. So we took her to the front of the
church and she was able to testify.
When the meeting was over, which is late
at night, her friend came to me and
said, "Patrick,
you have to follow her home. The demon
is at home." And I'm like, "Really?"
>> So I went I went home because it was
late. In the morning, 9:00, I got a call
that she can't speak again. So when I
got there, the pastor, her church pastor
was there and he passed me at the door
and said, "Patrick, you're in charge."
And he was gone.
>> I came inside and I said, "We're here to
pray for you." Her best friend was
sitting beside her and when I started to
say that, she bent over and say
something to her friend and her friend
said, "They say you're weak and you
can't get them out." And I keep
communicating with her and she
communicate to the friend to tell me.
And then I said, "Satan, we're going to
show you power. We're going to stop you
from listening and stop you from
speaking." And I just said, "Lord,
condescend by means of your holy spirit
and block this demon that they will not
hear and they will not speak." She never
spoke again.
>> Wow.
>> Until we cast out. So the authority and
knowing there's time when the demon
dialogue with me because of the
ministry.
I text a young lady one time and says I
we are praying for you. And the text
come back and says she don't want your
prayers. She's seated right by our side.
Don't pray for her. And I text back and
say Satan I rebuke you in Jesus name.
And the text come back and says when you
come to rebuke we won't be here. And I
said Satan let me tell you something. We
have father twothirds of the angel Jesus
Christ and the holy spirit more power on
our side. When I send that text nothing
came back. When I saw the young lady she
said I don't know. I said it was on your
phone. She said it just appear on my
phone. I didn't do it.
>> Whoa.
>> That was Satan. So what I'm trying to
say when you know the word of God and
you have the confidence that that we are
more than conquerors through Jesus
Christ you are not afraid to dialogue
you're not going to say okay because
you're not called you're not talking and
asking for favor you come with authority
and say listen you are doomed you got to
tell me who you are we have authority
over you I need to know your name now
under the blood of Jesus Christ and the
demon will like okay I'm going to tell
you right now or don't call for Gabriel.
I'm going to leave. They tremble. We're
not ordinary people, but we are acting
like ordinary. All a lot of people are
doing, my brother, is keep the fourth
commandment. They don't know God.
>> Amen.
>> There's a war going on. War.
>> We don't ready for this.
>> There was a a question in the comments.
I'm trying to find it real quick. I
think it was basically So, this is a
question. It says to ask Pastor Patrick
if he ever uses uh the himymn Oh, the
himynel power in the blood to cast out a
demon. Yes. So what what kind of is
there like you know any certain phrases
or song or what exactly is there a
certain method or like you said you you
get into the situation and you just
start asking God for help guide me what
do I need to say like
>> right
>> okay number one is the person have to
want to be free
>> okay
>> we met a lot of people who didn't want
to be free and they told us and we
showed them the door
>> they love what they're doing they love
the demon talking to them. You have to
be willing and you have to confess your
sins. Meaning, if you have unforgiveness
is one of the stronghold, somebody done
you wrong and you're holding things in
your heart. The devil uses that a lot.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you have to declutter. You have to
get rid of the stronghold or the occurs
things. There's hundreds. We could do
just a program and a curse things
paintings
>> um video games you know already there's
so many stronghold if we come to deliver
you through the blood of Jesus Christ
>> and there's a lot of stronghold the
demon not going to live and sometime
they won't manifest and if there's
unbelief with us they won't un manifest
because they don't want people to know
that they are real if they can keep you
in the unknown then but because they
know we know so they're not afraid to
manifest to us. So what we do now, we
get the person to confess.
When they confess, sometimes we get them
to read Psalms 3. And sometimes in
reading Psalms 3 over and over, the King
James version, not the New King James,
>> I agree with
>> when they reading the scripture over and
over, sometime the demon just stop them
from speaking and they can't speak
anymore. And right away now we are
clicking and start to pray. And they're
afraid of Revelation 12, Revelation 20,
Ezekiel 28,
Matthew 27, Matthew 28 from 1:7. They're
afraid of those scripture. Galatian the
1 verse4 15 they're afraid of.
There's so many scripture that they're
afraid of. So you got to study where the
devil, they're afraid of anything to do
with Jesus Christ risen. But when it
comes to the songs, there's some demon
that is played in through music.
Therefore, when the songs come and
worship, power in the blood. If you sing
power in the blood over and over and
over, the demon going to start to
manifest. They may just say once they
manifest, it easier to cast them out. If
the demon don't manifest, if you are
praying and say, "Lord, help this young
man here. You're seeing what he's going
through. Please Lord," and you anoint
him, the demon may be there and hiding.
>> Yeah.
>> Demon will hide. But when he manifest it
meant that or if the personal body is
getting hot because where the demon
usually go is in in the mind, in the
stomach or in the spine, the nervous
system. Those are the three major place
since that the demon go. So if you feel
your stomach heavy like the lady we
prayed for um couple days ago. She was
so heavy that two young people couldn't
get her to stand and by the time we
finished praying for her she was light.
They could lift her up easily because
sitting on her. So we have practical
explanation. So process is forgiveness
is the key and then you have to believe.
If you have doubt and unbelief the demon
is not going to leave and that's what's
wrong. Most people that we we prayed for
is 7day adventist and the ones that is
not 7day adventist get deliverance
faster.
>> Wow.
>> We pray people who are um alcoholic and
the demon came out spoke and came out
easily and they are set free. And these
people are Catholic. Some of them is not
Adventist. You're wondering how they get
free because they came, they're
vulnerable, they're opening up and says,
"I'm willing to share." When you have an
Adventist, they don't want to know, you
know, that they had an abortion. They
don't want you to know that they have
addiction to pornography. They don't
want to know that they're lesbian or
homosexual. So, they hide it. And then
you are praying for five hours and they
can't get deliverance. And then finally
the Lord reveal and say hey by the way
you went to a psychic and you're wearing
something a protection ring and then
they like I forgot I have it.
If you want deliverance you come clean
get rid of the the occurs things get rid
of the clutters and you start to forgive
people. The heart is serious. A lot of
people heart is not right. They cannot
be delivered. So the process is very
easy when the person is prepared and
they are willing. The deliverance comes
really easy.
>> Amen. I I believe that you know it's uh
a couple years ago I really started
seeing that forgiveness is a big deal to
God. You know forgive others or you will
not be forgiven. And um I I had some
people do some really bad things to me
in my past and I I've had to forgive
those people. People that robbed me and
and different things like that. But I
have forgiven everyone. I think it's a
huge deal. And I think Satan loves to
that's a door for Satan, you know. Um
something you were saying was this this
girl came and you were praying for her
and it was manifesting, but then when
she went home, she got possessed again
because of the things in her home,
right? So, it's really important to get
occultic items out of our house, whether
that's new age books or dream catchers
or if you're practicing yoga. Like,
there's a lot of things, right? Like,
what are
>> Yeah.
>> What are what are some things that
you've come to find out maybe that were
surprising that you didn't even know
about that um God told you it's this
item and they had to get rid of it? What
are some things that that you can inform
people to get rid of?
A lot of people buy um artificial stuff
like angels.
>> We went to a home where there was a
powerful demon there. And as a matter of
fact, I just spoke to the pastor a while
ago who went with me. And when we went
there, they have an angel.
>> There is two.
>> Yeah, there's twoirds of angel that the
Lord have and Satan have one third.
>> The Lord said don't make any graven
image of anything even the likeness of
it. But if you want to have angel, how
do you know an angel that is made in
China? You think it's one of the two
third angel?
>> Come on. So, so what I'm saying then we
find that images, carvings.
>> One of them number one things is over
your bed head. Take a look over the bed
head. They put some carving in China
that it have some eyes in it. Look good.
>> Take a look at your dining table and the
chairs. When you're praying, you kneel
down and bow to the chair. You're bowing
to Buddha. Buddha is in a good 80% of
furniture and the Greek goddess is
carved into the into the furnitureures.
So we see that they are into the fabric
like the paisley print
>> is a popular thing that every Adventist
have on their ties or they have
somewhere paisley print pulls demonic
power. um paintings
paintings a lot of the artists
especially some of the black art from
Africa and you see a mother holding a
little baby that mother is a voodoo
priest that's what they do they paint
voodoo priests get them in your home and
use it as a portal to get into your home
>> so we don't have the wisdom because we
don't ask God for example gifts if
somebody going to give you a gift
you have to know God have to tell you if
you should take it.
>> There was one time me and the same my
pastor friend here
>> there was a young lady who came to a
meeting I was running and she held up
her hand that her baby is waking up 2:00
every night and screaming right away I
know there's a demon in that room. So I
said when you go home touch everything
in the room and say the blood of Jesus
Christ and when you find out what it is
give me a call. She called me and told
me when she switched the switch on, a
lamp came on and the lamp is not
attached to the switch.
>> Oh.
>> And when she go and touch it, a power
coming from the lamp. And she said now
she got her husband with her and they
both touch it and a power. So they took
it out. I told them to put it in the
garage. I went to visit her, me and my
friend, the pastor. And we went into the
garage. We felt our hair tingling.
Something about the lamp. Where did you
get the lamp? I got it from my
grandmother.
>> So we say, okay, the puzzle was solved
two years after
>> she went back home to where her
grandmother is and went into the
basement and saw a Freemason monument
>> and she said, "Grandma, what are you
doing with this?" And she said, "Oh, you
didn't know that your grandfather is a
grandmaster in the lodge?"
>> That's where the lamp is coming from. So
he bought that lamp with his money that
is cursed. is handed down to her as an
Adventist. The devil have legal rights.
>> Yeah.
>> So therefore, God's people need to pray
about everything. Do not navigate
through life without praying every
moment. Everything comes in your house.
You got to know where it is. Go into
your children room. Look on the wall. Do
you know the painting? Do you know what
character? Are you have Batman on the
wall? Do you know where Batman comes
from? Come on.
>> He's Hades. have Pokemon in in in the
child game Pokemon.
>> Yeah, man. There's so many things that
we have culturally accepted.
>> Uh because culture is like Satan's guys,
you know, it's like we we exposed the
game or the uh the cartoons anime.
They're so demonic and and a lot of it
is dragon worship and stuff like this.
And we were called by people racist
because they said that's their culture.
And I said, I don't care what you call
it. Culture doesn't make sin not sin.
The Bible says that the dragon, that old
serpent, is going to deceive the entire
world. And that the whole world's going
to worship the dragon. And you look
around at all these cultures and you see
people worshiping dragons and serpents.
You can't call sin culture and it makes
it okay. Um, some cultures marry their
own relatives. Some cultures marry
children. Are we going to say that
pedophilia is okay because well that's
just a cultural thing. No way. You know,
but when it comes to
>> their ancestors, they worship their
ancestors.
>> Exactly.
>> Voodoo's culture, all this stuff. Um I
got a a quick little clip I want to
show. It just came to me because I had
watched this and this guy made some
really good points and I want to see
what you think about it. It's It's
pretty short, maybe 2 minutes or so.
>> Okay.
>> It's a term that I learned in the
demonic realm called legal, right?
>> The entire demonic kingdom is obsessed
with this term. You'll find men and
women on earth who practice volleyball,
basketball, football, and they get good
at that. Somebody who's well known in
the demonic kingdom is someone who's
versed in a term called legal right. So
the better that they understand the word
of God and the heart of God to cause
someone to sin against it is what's
legal right. God said don't when you do
there's repercussions
not because God's just angry and mad but
it's for the safety of his kingdom for
the well-being of a man. There's
repercussions to disobeying God. The
devil
has obsessed over this. So you can
imagine the man with legion of demons in
him. What things did that man do to
allow those demons to possess him in
such a way? And Satan has wrapped this
up into a ritual, a fivepoint major
defilement pentagram ritual. I call it
pentagram because the way it's always
been shown to me is the is the upside
down star with the circle around it.
[clears throat] I've been shown how each
point of that represents five major
folds of defilement. That circle to
Satan is an open door into a man, right?
So all of humankind is constantly trying
to go to the spiritual realm. It's all a
distraction while Satan manifests
through mankind into this reality. And
that defilement ritual will open a man
up. It's worship of self, false god
worship, sorcery, which I've been shown
is anything from addictive foods,
chemical compounds, physical addictions,
and using pharmarmacia or foods or
poisons to open someone up spiritually
or control them. That is what I've been
taught by demons is sorcery. And then
the next thing would be exalting, using,
and practicing magic. I have some really
deep thoughts on this and revelation,
but if you can't accept that just the
way that we've been glorifying magic
through say the Disney Channel
>> alone is enough to understand it. When
you study Crowley, okay, Crowley
constantly was in this same pattern in
his rituals, getting women addicted to
drugs, right? Practicing magic with
them, worshiping themselves, worshiping
these false gods from Egypt, right? It's
all relies around this ritual. And the
last thing is sex, lust, and trauma. So
that's this fivepoint major pentagram
ritual I have been taught over and over
and over exceeds all the boundaries of
the legal right Satan needs to possess a
man or a nation or a people. You have it
is a term that I learned.
>> So there was a lot in there, but I I
think he made a lot of good points, man.
cuz
>> yeah,
>> you know, I I've I've been down this
rabbit hole of the Illuminati and the
elites and all this stuff since uh 2012,
and I've seen a lot of evidence that
show that some of these celebrities and
stuff have to do some very disgusting
things, you know, whether it's at a a
party or whatever, but it goes beyond
just sexual things. It goes into
uh consuming feces and all kinds of
stuff. And I always thought that was so
crazy. I was like, why would these
people do this? Why would they do this
the most disgusting things? And it's
because anything that defiles us allows
Satan into our life. You know, God says,
"Don't eat this because it's unclean."
So, what do you think happens when
people are saying, "You know what? That
the law has been done away with. I can
eat this filthy swine." What is that
actually doing? We're making ourselves
unclean. You are what you eat. You're
making yourself unclean. I think you're
allowing you're opening a door for the
enemy to come in or if you're messing
around with drugs or watching, you know,
um Disney and all these things that
glorify the occult. What do you think?
>> Okay, I'm going to share something that
really powerful. How the legal rights
work. The devil needs legal rights. And
when you have legal rights, it's harder
to cast him out. M
>> a lot of people in the world like Diddy
and some of these people that open big
doors what they do they are so possessed
that the demon will come inside of them
and navigate and work against people.
They don't have no rights.
>> They are so possessed that the demon
will take them out. Let me tell you what
the de what the devil uses within the
Adventist church. He use subtle things.
I know I pray for a young lady was which
came out of Haiti and she was having a
sexual demon. She's Adventist and the
demon will come up and intimate with her
and tell her what he's going to do. I'm
going to let green stuff all over you.
And he did.
>> And she wake up and say green stuff all
over. And she said to me, "I don't know
what's wrong every time."
>> And when we pray, I pray that God will
remind her. And then she remembered that
when she was a little girl, like three
or four years old, the family used to go
into the backyard and there was a statue
that they used to worship.
From the moment we found that out, the
deliverance start because she now
confess and say Lord I was young and I
don't want to be part of that worshiping
any ancestors. And from that now the
legal rights start to be broken. So some
legal rights. There was one I have to
tell you about. There's this young lady
we have seen God use with much power
than I've ever seen in all the life of
this ministry.
>> This young lady, we done some cases
where people are missing and God will
tell us where the people are and tell us
what's wrong with where they are like
word for word wish where they are like
powerful things. Wow.
>> So hear this. There was one day, she's
not around anymore praying with us, you
know, and what happened is that one day
she called me and says that there was a
demon talking to her and saying that
she's not going to be saved.
>> She heard the voice come and said,
"You're going to be lost." And she's
crying and I said, "That demon is a
liar. They don't want you to be saved.
>> Once we serve God and confess, you will
be saved." So I said, "Okay, here what
we're going to cast that demon out now
that he's talking to you." You know, we
don't put things off, you know.
Sometimes people call me and the
deliverance comes within half an hour if
God permits it. Because I'm not, you're
not going to call me and I answer.
That's why I don't answer because once I
answer, I'm going to say, "We're doing
it now. Demon, you have no power. We are
people that serve God." So I said,
"Listen, we're going to pray now." So
when I started to pray for her, the
demon start to speak and said, "Listen,
we're not letting this one go because
she is a priestess. God has called her
and she mess up and we are not letting
her go."
>> So I said, "In the name of Jesus Christ,
what is your legal rights?" He said,
"She disobeyed God." And because she
disobeyed God. So I said, "Okay, then
tell me what you need to do so you can
leave in Jesus Christ's name."
>> You have to use the name of Jesus
Christ. It's not your answer.
>> Authority.
>> It's not your power. It is.
>> Yeah. Amen. All power is good to the
Lord. So hear this. The demon says she
have to confess this the sin of
disobedience.
I stop everything and say confess. She
start to say, "Pray Lord, please forgive
me. I've messed up. You told me what to
do and I disobeyed you. And she prayed.
When she finished praying, I said,
"Satan," she confessed, "So I have now
the rights over you, legal rights to
cast you out. You have no more legal
rights to stay in because of
disobedience." So therefore, and he's
like, "No, no, no." And I started to
say, "In the name of Jesus," and I start
to call for Jesus because I know this is
a powerful demon. So I call for Jesus
himself. When I start to call for Jesus,
I just heard the young lady say,
"Michael is here."
>> Wow.
>> And the demon fled. All the demon fled
from her body. But listen to this. Did
you know that somebody sent a message
and said, "How could you say Michael is
there and the Bible said you can't see
Jesus?"
>> But and said that person is spiritually
already blocked. You know what I mean?
That person don't spiritual things are
spiritually discerned. God can do
anything. Listen
the discernment alone know that Michael
came down. You don't have to see
Michael. You know his present.
>> So listen.
>> So this then when Michael was gone, the
Holy Spirit start to speak through her.
You see a lot of people I have a lot of
encounters where the spirit of the Lord
spoke through the person. The spirit of
the Lord says from this moment food must
not touch her lips.
She must fast for seven days without
food. Wow.
>> And and if she don't and disobey the
demon of disobey and should shall return
with much power.
>> Listen, she did fast seven days without
food or without water. Seven days.
I'm just telling you a little tip of the
iceberg. The power that we serve. We're
as Adventists. If we stop from being
afraid and tap into this power, Lord
have mercy. When you walk in a place,
you know, all the demon back out and run
out the place. Listen, when an Adventist
walking to certain place, Mikey, and you
go in there, you walk in with the
entourage of righteous angel. You can
call Gabriel and say, "Gabriel, I'm
going in this place. Come with me."
>> Amen.
>> We don't believe.
>> No.
>> Lord, Lord, Lord. You know, the Bible
says you have not because you ask not.
You know, we need to call upon God when
we're But like you said, we're just
afraid to even go there. And like you
said, too about when you kind of add at
the end of a prayer, if it be your will,
that is casting doubt because you're
saying, I don't I don't think this
prayer is going to be answered. So, I'll
just add if it's your will, and if it
doesn't happen, then I can say, well, it
wasn't God's will.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think as believers, we we know
what's God's will. Sometimes there there
are certain cases where things happen
and you're like, I don't know why this
is happening, but God has allowed it
because, you know, like Joseph being
thrown into the the pit and things like
that.
>> But for the most part, healing is God's
will. You know, um, of course,
>> being set free from demonic oppression,
>> you have to persist. You can't when you
pray one time and it don't happen for
healing. You got to go back again. And
you go back. We go back like 10 times
until the deliverance comes.
>> Amen.
>> We don't we don't back down. And when
the devil comes in and tell you it won't
be done, anytime the devil tell you you
don't have no power, he tell me that all
the time. I said, you're right. But I
know who have the power. His name is
Jesus Christ. And then he said, "Okay,
don't say that name." [laughter]
>> Amen.
>> No, but I got to tell you this one. I
got to tell you this one. The Lord just
impressed me. There was one time a lady
from UK
messaged me sent an email in and says
every time she listen to my sturman
voices coming from her. So I said okay
could you send me your number I want to
talk to you. I talked to her. She said
yeah. So I said let's test it now. I'm
going to get you to read Psalms 3. When
she start to read Psalms 3
she just reach halfway and and can't
speak. And I say, "In the name of Jesus
Christ, let her go." And I start to pray
and she start to vomit. And she vomited
like for two hours. And then I heard
boom. I said, "What happened?" She said,
"They pick me up and throw me against
the wall. They pick her up again. Throw
up against the other wall." I heard the
sound
>> and then she vomited and I thought
everything was over. I was feeling
relief. It's three hours now. And I
heard a voice says, "You cast those ones
out, but you can't cast me out." I said,
"Who are you in Jesus name?" He said,
"My name is Beloveub. You can't cast me
out."
>> And I said, "Believe, we're going to
call for Jesus
>> to cast you out now."
>> And he said, "By the way, Patrick, your
ministry is powerful, but you don't have
enough people.
>> Call me by name." So now I said, "We
will get enough people. Don't worry
about that." So I start to pray and then
he said the Sunday law is coming. I said
I don't need you to tell me that
[laughter] if you have a demon telling
us that Sunday life is coming when
Adventists don't believe that the Sunday
law is coming.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't need you to tell me. And then
the most powerful thing he did, he took
me to the the crucifixion.
>> I heard in the background, crucify him.
Crucify him. And I heard the noise a
noise like and I said in the name of
Jesus and I I went to the next level
with prayer to calm the crowd the demon
that he was conjuring and that's when
after another hour the deliverance came
where the lady came back to herself and
was able to talk to me. We seeing this
thing but we are sharing this thing to
let the people know around the world
that we are not ordinary. You are not
ordinary. If you see yourself as
ordinary, we are remnant of the remnant.
We are not ordinary in Jesus name. We
are people that keep the commandments of
God. We are seventh day Adventist.
Listen, a lot of people said, "Are you
sure? Are you Adventist?" [laughter]
>> I said, "Who you think have the power?
You think is is is a Pentecostal and we
have the power, but we are denied the
power."
>> Come on.
>> I said born and bred. If you ever heard
anything contradicting on my channel,
you'll never hear that. Everything at
300 message, the word of God, everything
is 100%. It's never any dilution.
Everything is about the word because
>> this deliverance ministry is going to be
in every single
>> churches around the globe. Every
Adventist church. Yes. That's what's
locking.
>> I believe it. You know, we're we're
going to we are ramping up to seeing
more manifestations than ever in our
lifetime. You know, the the military is
on the news saying that yeah, yeah, we
talk to non-human intelligences. They're
are they alien? Well, we don't know if
they're alien. They could be
interdimensional beings. I mean, when
the military is on the news telling you,
"We talk to interdimensional beings,"
it's about to get really weird and a lot
of people are just going to be deceived
into thinking that these beings are from
other worlds or whatever. You know, the
the spirits of their dead loved ones.
Satan's got a disguise for every
manifestation he has. And if we are
afraid to go into battle with these
things, then,
>> you know, I think Satan's weakened us
down, man. Weakened us down with, oh,
don't don't believe in that stuff. You
know, that's not real.
>> Yeah. Yeah. They're not real. You know,
don't talk about demon. Talk about good
things.
>> When the people are suffering, people in
the church, the children,
demonpossessed,
Lord have mercy.
>> Yeah, we we get it all the time. People
say, "All you guys do is talk about the
devil all the time." I mean, you know,
you think there's a devil under every
rock. Why don't you just talk about
Jesus? It's like, because we're all
different parts of the body of Christ.
We all have a different mission. I'm I'm
all for any ministry that's out there
lifting up Christ. But I see every day
[clears throat] thousands of people who
claim to be Christian, who are watching
the filthiest things on television,
playing the most violent video games,
thinking it's okay to do yoga, you know,
and they need to see the truth behind
these deceptions. We are not supposed to
be ignorant of his devices. We're
supposed to expose darkness. Because if
you see your friend walking towards the
edge of a cliff, is it loving to just
say, "Well, I should just talk about
Jesus." Or, "No, you're going to yell
out, "Beware, there's a cliff in front
of you." It's loving to give a warning.
And we are called to be the watchmen.
We're we're called to
>> um, you know, sound the alarm, sound the
trumpet when we see the enemy coming.
Listen my brother, we are overworked
so badly until I can't tell you. For the
last
five or six days, we have done so many
delivers. We have prayed for hours,
hours,
>> hours have lick sleep. We cannot find
enough people
>> because people are afraid.
>> I know it's true.
>> The Lord have mercy.
>> I want to show them the your YouTube
channel. This is their live. You guys
need to subscribe to Button to Christ.
Go to the website.
>> It's Button to Christ. But look at these
lives.
>> Five and a half hours. He's not joking,
man. I I've I've watched these these
sermons, man. Four hours and 45 minutes.
[laughter] You guys go to battle, man. I
I've been watching the sermons and next
thing you know you're not even on stage
anymore because somebody's screaming out
in the audience and you guys have to
start praying.
>> Yeah, we stop the sermon. If some a
demon manifest, we stop and get to work.
Amen.
>> This is real work. And that's why we go
to churches, my brother, and we have 500
people lining up and we can't get out of
the church for days. Forget about
eating. And that's what we are
practicing to fast. And we have a few
soldiers who are willing. They will not
eat food. They will tar. They will camp
out until people are delivered. And
that's why the Lord is giving us
strength.
>> But God is want to recruit more people.
>> Amen.
>> Who are willing and who are ready for
this assault.
>> I'm telling you,
>> if you're you're asking for help, if
there's somebody watching right now that
says, "I've been looking for this exact
ministry. I want to get involved." How
can they get involved with your
ministry? You're in Canada, but can you
get help from people that are in the
states or how does this work?
>> Okay. All right. I have one of my
brothers on, you know, who was
delivered. He's in UK right now with his
family. His 8-year-old was possessed.
And when we start to pray for the
8-year-old, after much prayer, probably
weeks, God revealed that the demon is in
him. And when we start to pray for him,
the demons start to speak to us like me
and you're talking here and he himself
shock since his deliverance.
God have been using him. So what we do,
we connect with zoom in UK.
Him and his wife stayed up until 3:00
sometime 4:00 and they going work
working for God.
>> Wow.
>> We have people in New York. We have
people in in in in different states.
that is part of the ministry and we zoom
them in when we are praying and
delivering somebody over zoom and they
come in so it doesn't matter where you
are we have people in Africa there was a
lady sister Grace came on from Africa
from was it uh from somewhere in Africa
and hear this she have a she was had a
bleeding and doctor's medication
couldn't stop the bleeding she was on
Sabbath and she sent me a message that
since we prayed for her on Sabbath, just
this Sabbath, the bleeding is stopped.
>> Wow.
>> That woman and her sister are very
powerful Adventists. God has called them
to. We have people all over the world
that zoom in. If you want to get in
touch with us, send us a email and said
this is a ministry that the Lord has
been calling me to. We're going to have
agent where the enemy going to send, but
God will reveal who they are. You know,
if the agent think they can sneak in,
they can't sneak in because God will
show us.
>> That's how we minister. There's no Judas
going to come and hang around for long.
God is going to say that person is not
working for me.
>> And the devil will find you out when we
delivering people. The devil will say,
"Where you get that person from? Where
do you come from? Who are you?"
>> Trust me. Go ahead. Go ahead. So button
the number two button2christ.com/cont
if you guys want to get involved in this
ministry or if you need prayer yourself
and you feel like you are just falling
into the same sins all the time that
Satan has a hold of you. They will pray
with you. You know um these brothers and
sisters have prayed for my mom when she
was in the hospital and they are
serious. They're fasting. They'll come
on and pray for an hour and then they
they'll set up another time to pray. You
guys are the real deal, man. I've seen
it firsthand. I love your ministry. I
love what you guys are doing. I'm so
glad that somebody's out here doing the
work. Um I do have a final question. It
it keeps coming up and we lightly
addressed it, but there is this idea
that you're not supposed to talk to the
demons. So, do you have any
rebuttal for that? like is do you have
any scripture or something? You know, we
we talked about Jesus talked to Legion.
I think that's a huge one.
>> Okay. A lot of people um they read Roger
Mano book.
>> Mhm.
>> And in the trip into the supernatural he
said it's not good to talk to demon but
listen what we experience Rajimano
experience 5% of what we experience.
>> Yeah. some encounters we have. We could
do a six-part series for you just
sharing 10% of testimonies.
>> It's true.
>> So therefore, what I'm telling you now,
when you go in the name of the Lord, you
don't go with rules and say I can't talk
to demon because the spirit of the lord
is going to tell you what to do.
Sometime the Lord there's some demon
like last night the demon was speaking
and we couldn't stop the demon from
speaking no matter what scripture you
know what we have to do start to sing
>> power in the blood and we keep singing
singing singing power in the blood and
and all the songs and then the demon
become mute because the worship
>> wow
>> so what I'm saying because there's a
difference between witches sometime when
I command the demon like last night I
will say are you a demon or a witch? And
he said, "I'm a demon."
>> Because the witch is able to astrop
project and go into the person's body.
>> Right?
>> We have a woman and a man astrop project
from Africa who is a witch and come in
her body and he will tell me
>> and he will said I am sent to kill him
and I'm from Africa.
And there was one case I I always go the
extra mile. There was one case I did in
Vancouver. I went to visit them, you
know, this Sabbath evening and both
young people drop on the ground and
start to go like real snake all over the
floor and they're coming right by my
feet and I say, "I subdue you." And then
a woman start to speak to the young man.
And I said, "Who are you?" And he said,
"My name is Mary. I'm from downstairs.
I'm a witch." And I was sent into his
body. I said, "Here what? I'm going to
show you the power. Satan is going to
kill you. You can confess your sin and
the Lord can save you. And she said, "If
I do that, Satan will kill my daughter."
I said, "What is your daughter name?"
She told me, I said, "I will pray for
protection over your daughter and over
you if you confess to the Lord."
>> Amen.
>> And she said, "Okay, okay. I'm going to
confess then." And I say, "Confess in
the name." Say the prayer now. And she
said, "Lord Jesus, please. This voice is
coming from the man, a woman We're
telling people who don't believe. And
she said, "Lord Jesus, I confess my sin.
I'm sorry. Please forgive me for
everything I've done. I commit. I give
my life over to you." And when she done,
she said, "I'm leaving now." And I just
hear
>> she came out.
>> Then a man came in and said, "I'm from
Africa and I don't want to hear nothing
about no Jesus. I come to kill."
>> As a matter of fact, I'm gone.
that we couldn't reason with him because
his mind was made up. He's gone. There's
some de witches that says, "I've gone
too far. I've done too many ritual. I
can't turn back anymore."
>> You know, but Lord have mercy.
>> Nobody's too far gone. Nobody's too far
gone until you take your last breath.
Nobody's too far gone, you know. Never
believe the lie. If if you ever have
that doubt in your mind like I I I'm too
far gone, then that's enough proof to
tell you that you're not. Because when
you're too far gone, I will say there
might be for some people a point where
somebody's done so much wickedness,
they've rejected the Holy Spirit over
and over and over to the point where
they've grieved the Holy Spirit and
their close of probation has come. But
that person will never have the thought,
I wonder if I've gone too far because
you won't even be thinking about God.
You're not even thinking about
repentance at all. So if if you ever
have the doubt
>> that you've gone too far, just know that
that's proof that you haven't.
>> Amen.
>> God can forgive anyone, man. Murderers,
rapists, everybody that you know, the
thief on the cross was nailed to a cross
right there next to Christ and said,
"Lord, remember me when you come into
your kingdom." And he said, "I promise
you, you will be with me in my kingdom."
>> I mean, that's it's amazing.
>> Great hope.
>> Amen. The word is so powerful, Mikey.
When we study the word and digest the
word of God and use the word and the
demon, they are so afraid. They're so
weak. They just pretend and they pretend
and make people so fearful. When people
listen to the program last night, I
hopefully Sabbath I could interview some
of the people who are under deliverance
because they are like we never heard
anything like this in our life. Like you
ever heard anything like this? The demon
tell us how they got in, what they did
in the family. They were in the family
from centuries ago and how they are
demon of poverty and what they did. They
said, "Oh my god." And I'm like,
"Sister, we heard this all the time."
>> So we have the people even on the team
marvel and say, "My God, we never
experienced this level. God is going to
take us to high level." But we have to
be willing.
>> I'm willing to go all the way for Jesus
Christ. live, die, I am willing to go
all the way because there's thousands of
people need help and we need to roll up
our sleeves, come in the word and be
determined to finish the work. We need
to stop the foolishness.
>> We have the power as Seventh Day
Adventists. We have the power. We better
claim it.
>> Amen.
>> Yes.
>> Amen. Well, that was a perfect ending
right there, man. You know, there's
there's a lot of work to be done. And
I'm like you. you, me and my wife, we
are both fully surrendered. And we tell
God in prayer, we're like, I'm a willing
vessel for you. Use me, Lord. This world
has nothing to offer me. I've had a
taste of all of it. It's all vanity,
vanity. I will never go back to the
things of this world. I'll never, you
know, surrender to anything of this
world because I know where that road
leads. And all I want to do is spend
eternity with Christ. And all I want to
do is win as many people to his kingdom
as possible. And I I want to be a part
of what you guys are doing. I want to be
able to uh ask God to cast out devils.
And that's why I wanted to have you on
because, you know, I think I think there
are other people that they they have a
genuine desire, but they're just it's
that unknown. You know, it's this
fearful thing that people don't want to
talk about and so there's not a lot of
solid answers. So, I like how you've
addressed some of these things headon.
you know how what Roger Morno said and
what you've experienced firsthand and I
think you've proven it that when you
speak to these things with authority and
tell them what let you in and what's
going to get make you get out they have
to tell you in the name of Jesus under
his authority they have to tell you the
truth
>> and that gives you understanding on oh
okay we need to get this out of your
house you need to confess this and now
come out
>> yes Yes, that's what the Lord does, my
friend. The Lord is powerful, my friend.
When we experience the word of God,
we're not going to look back, man. I'm
so happy. And I'm like, Lord, take me
higher. Every day, I want higher because
we are exposed to the things behind the
scene. We need to ask God for more
power.
>> Wake up, everybody before it's too late.
>> Yep. Time is running out. We on this
channel, we show all the signs of the
times. I I will be shocked if we're
still around after 2030. You know, it's
just so many things are lining up this
showing that that Satan is about to
appear as as Christ and it's going to
deceive many many people because we
don't understand prophecy and we're at
such a a hopeless state that we're
looking for a savior and that's when
Satan's going to appear. you know, he's
going to appear doing lying signs and
wonders and uh miracle working demons
and a lot of people are going to fall
for it.
>> One more thing, the Lord is saying to me
right now that he's already appearing
>> because we adopting all his principle,
his movies, his music, everything we're
bringing in, he's already up here and we
are marrying it and saying that it's
Christ.
>> We are so fooled.
>> Lord have mercy.
>> It's so true. I see it all the time how
people have just merged the ideas of
Christianity with the new age and pagan
ideas. And man, it Christianity is just
such a muddied up waters right now. I
feel bad for people that are just coming
into the truth and trying to figure out
all this stuff, you know, and that's
that's why we just got to keep doing
what we're doing, man. keep pointing
people to to the word to Christ and keep
exposing darkness so that people can get
on that straight and narrow.
>> Of course.
>> Well, brother Patrick, Pastor Patrick,
thank you so much for coming on this
show and sharing these stories and
sharing some wisdom and some insight on
deliverance ministry. Um, is there
anything you want to say, a final word
or anything? I want people to make sure
that they know where to find you to go
to buttontochrist.com.
Yeah.
>> Button of Christ on YouTube.
>> Yes. Or send us an email. And I know we
are jammed up though. We have like
thousands of people trying to reach us.
But
>> just keep trying. And when you're
trying, pray and ask the Lord to open a
way based on the emergency of your case.
God will show you what to do and you
will reach us on the right time. God is
an ontime God. So we love you.
>> Amen. Thank you so much, brother. Stick
around and I'll talk to you after the
show. I'm going to sign off.
>> Okay,
>> guys. Thank you so much for being here
tonight. That was amazing. Those are
some powerful stories. And if it
inspired you, please give this video a
thumbs up. It really helps to get this
video out into the algorithm so more
people can find out the truth on
deliverance ministries. And if they're
having an issue, they know a ministry
that's out there, that's serious, that's
real, that is calling upon the name of
Jesus to cast out devils like we were
told to do by Jesus himself. Go into all
the world, heal the sick, raise the
dead, and cast out devils. If you guys
are new to this channel, please click
subscribe. If you would like to support
this channel, go to cantruth.org. We got
many ways to give. Cash App, Vinmo, Zel,
PayPal. We even have Patreon. And we got
some cool merchandise. If you guys would
like to buy a cool t-shirt or hoodie or
mug or anything, we got a lot of
different merch out there. We get about
$5 on every sale from that. And it
really helps this ministry. We cannot do
this without you guys. We are fully 100%
donationbased except for when we get
invited to speak. So if you would like
to invite Candid Truth to come speak at
your church, go to cantruth.org and
click on the booking tab to see our
calendar. We love you guys. We thank
you. We cannot do this without you. And
we will see you next time on Candid
Truth.